hello everyone welcome to this
conference session
on doing statistics in julia
i am going to do an introductory talk on
some of the big ideas
then after that you're going to get a
bunch of specific talks on individual
packages
and
problem areas
and then finally we're going to go into
a panel discussion with some of the cool
people who are building things in this
field okay so let's get started
for me the point of departure is of
course r most people in the world of
statistics tend to use are
and it's important for us to understand
the strengths and weaknesses
of the r world
the first thing to emphasize is that the
strength of the r packages is simply
remarkable
there's been
thousands of people who have built
extremely high quality packages in r and
there's a lot to be said
for
the
intellectual capacity and the high
software quality that has gone into the
our package ecosystem
now
from the viewpoint of a statistics user
there are many things about the syntax
of r which come quite naturally which
come quite readily
particularly if you want to write 510
lines
it's a domain specific language which is
meticulously convenient
for the people in the space of data
science for the people in the space of
statistics
but that has come at a price
and some of the clean computer science
principles
of simplicity consistency
have been sacrificed in return for that
ease of
uh extremely nice 510 line script and i
think that these trade-offs have started
showing particularly now that we are
doing really enormously complex things
using r so
i think that there is modern computer
science knowledge about what is a simple
clean consistent programming language
and the trade-off that r achieved was an
approachability and ease of access
for the world of statistics in return
for sacrificing some of the simplicity
and consistency in the world of computer
science
the next thing i want to point out is
that
the
world of r programming has actually
split into two somewhat different
kinds of languages
there are the
r programs written by old timers like me
and then there is the hadley verse the
tidy verse which is actually in many
ways a very different language many
times it seems like the two groups can
barely read each other's code so the our
world is not as monolithic as it seems
yes of course we can call each other's
packages but the ability to read the
other person's program
has diminished i am reminded of a joke
about pearl that it's a write-only
language if you read your own code of a
few years ago you can't remember what
the hell you were thinking i know i have
been in that place myself
and then we get to the problem of
performance
in the last 10 15 years
data set sizes have simply exploded and
it is difficult to achieve high
performance in r owing to some basic
language design features that will not
be readily eliminated without breaking
compatibility with the language
so as a consequence many researchers
many applications in the industry end up
having to put in extra effort to
overcome performance bottlenecks there
are broadly
two approaches for doing this
either we go more intensively into
parallel computation or we write
something using rcpp or we're linking
into ancient fortran codes and that of
course comes at a cost so
this is not free it the most important
resource is not the cpu but the human
mind and the kind of effort many people
are taking when confronted with these
performance gaps is quite immense
my last idea in this is of course the
familiar julia argument about the two
language problem particularly when there
is a separation between a research stage
and a deployment stage it tends to often
be the case that there is this step of
studying the data and arriving at
certain models which is done in r and
then something is rewritten
in c or fortran or something else to be
suitable to a real world enterprise
deployment and that is painful and
expensive so i think that there's a two
language problem at two levels many our
packages contain a great deal of c and
fortran and then there is the deployment
problem where enterprise i.t
applications tend to demand converting
from an experimental or a research
coding r into a production code into
something else so this is my sense of
what is happening in the our landscape
well what are the possibilities with
julia and how does it shape our thinking
for the field of statistics my sense is
that
10-15 years of progress in programming
language design and software engineering
has gone into julia i feel the syntax is
clean it is simple it is elegant it is
consistent particularly when you go
beyond
10 lines 50 lines to
500 lines the differences are palpable
and it's just a cleaner place to be
building stuff so i feel that
the productivity of the programmer has
gone up considerably thanks to the 10-15
years of progress and the simplicity of
the language i think julia has been more
careful about laying down the clean
lines of modern programming language
design
and then there are the performance gains
everybody talks about how julia is
better
i want to tell a story about our own
experience you're going to see the talk
about the survey package that my
colleagues have built and in the survey
package
we have seen that while we have enormous
respect and admiration for the work that
thomas lumley and others did in building
the survey package we find that
our
small julia implementation of similar
concepts for certain similar problems is
giving performance gains like a hundred
times 100 times is a lot and it matters
materially for the kind of projects that
we are doing and then exactly as i said
a moment ago if
the person doing the applied statistics
is investing time
in going poly language or in doing a lot
of work on parallel computation or in
the separation between research and
deployment then some of these problems
are eased because in julia we get to go
with the one language and the same
language can go all the way to a
production deployment so i think this is
the case for julia that there is value
added from the simplicity the elegance
the consistency
of a modern programming language and a
supporting modern software engineering
environment
in my opinion the single place where the
greatest
translation of this promise of julia
into a living reality has taken place
lies in bayesian computation
in the world of bayesian computation
we've gone through a long journey of
bugs and then jags and then stan and in
its own way we have had this two
language problem all through so you know
we are
uh finding ourselves in the place of
writing an r program inside which there
is a stand program and that is its own
kind of two language problem
and
there was a natural opportunity to make
an all julia workflow because julia has
the modern computer science through
which the bayesian model can be written
in pure julia
and
there could have been an approach of
doing something more modest but i really
admire the people who have done touring
who have done sauce and they have played
this at a higher level they played this
at a bigger scale and i feel it's not an
exaggeration today to say that the best
bayesian statistics today in the whole
world
is done in julia using turing and source
and i think these are remarkable
packages and they have not done a mere
implementation of scan in julia but
they've gone and thought this afresh
using the modern computer science
opportunities of julia and in my mind
this is a foretaste of where we can go
in statistics in julia so we are not
there there are many pieces that need to
be done but in my mind this is a demo of
what a transformative gain can be
obtained
by rethinking statistics from the ground
up using julia
and that takes us to the perennial
debate that when we build statistics for
julia should we go for something that is
more comprehensible for the installed
base that is coming from our okay the
bulk of the statistics of the world
today is done in our and so there are
certain metaphors there are certain
interfaces that a lot of the user base
is used to or should we go deep into a
native julia world of rethinking of
reimagining how these things can be done
in the julia world and while of course
there will be this perennial debate in
my opinion i feel we should lay the
foundations for a more profound gain
as the turing and sauce people did and
so i feel that maybe there should be a
compatibility layer there should be
code generators like the old f2c
there should be many many crutches using
which the installed base can choose to
move more readily but fundamentally a
programming language that has not
changed the way you think about
programming is not worth learning as the
old fortune goes and here i think our
opportunity is to rethink this as a at a
deeper level so just like s was a
revolution just like r has been a
revolution i feel there is an
opportunity here
to think about statistics from the
ground up
in a new way to bring new imagination to
bear on this and to build a new world
which will actually be more expressive
and come closer to our thinking as
statisticians and make it easier and
nicer for us to do statistical research
so we're not competing with anybody else
in this game we're competing with
ourselves let's build something good
now in this i think it's important
to see that
we don't need to leave the richness of
our our packages behind
our call is always there and so we are
never stranded
so in fact whenever there is a
particular specialized estimator which
is done very well by an r package great
we should use it so as an example
i have worked on an r package called fx
regime which estimates structural breaks
in the exchange rate regime it is
perfectly accessible using our call so i
feel that
our way forward lies first in focusing
on the 90 of the lines of a project
which are actually the everything else
only 10 of the lines of a project are
the actual statistical estimation so our
focus should be on the foundations the
data structures the expressivity of the
syntax how we hook up to databases how
we connect into maps the whole
complexity of handling data managing
data manipulating data which actually
eats up 90 of our time and effort and
lines of code these are the key choke
points once these are done well
we are ready to move projects into julia
and i hope the julia statistics world
already adds value when compared with
some of the difficulties of our our
world and when it comes to the
specialized
estimator we can always use our call and
drop into a beautiful r package and get
our estimation done so i feel of a
priority in building the julia
statistics ecosystem should be the
everything else it should be data
structures syntax expressivity and the
surrounding infrastructure of databases
and maps and parallel computation and so
on
so here's an example from our life
we love data frames what
the pioneers in julia and
bogomil have done in data frames is
wonderful
and
in the field of time series we feel that
there is remarkable capability in the r
world first in terms of the
zoo package and then in terms of the xts
package they have built a whole set of
metaphors and convenient
expressions through which the finance
macro and a whole array of other
subjects are able to do time series
analysis
so we built a julia package that is
called tsx which borrows a lot of these
metaphors and implements them using data
frames so it turns out that
all the functions that we have built in
tsx are just one or at most two lines of
data frames but the point is that they
pick up
the world of a time series programmer to
a higher level and so that we're not
doing complex data frames manipulations
but we get the simplicity and the beauty
of the zoo and xts syntax so that
basically you could be doing a complex
time series oriented finance macro
project
in a julia workflow and then of course
there will be times when you're doing a
complex
estimation of some likelihood function
at that time it may well make sense for
a long time to drop into an r package to
get your estimation done but the
viability of the main macro finance
workflow being done in julia critically
required
this
replacement for a zoo xts and so we
chose to build that
in the tsx package
so what is our strategy going forward
our strategy is that we
are doing many interesting academic and
other applied research projects
in julia we are building applied
statistics projects entirely in julia
every now and then we encounter an
important bottleneck and then we try to
go and solve it and we don't stop at
half measures we do the full software
engineering we build test cases we write
documentation we fit it into the
existing julia package ecosystem but our
main driver is that we are researchers
and we are doing applied statistics
papers
with each of our papers we are releasing
the complete reproducible research code
so that other people can see complete
paper implementations being done in
julia and that may help many other
people think about this and you know
hopefully build better stuff
based on what we are doing
so far we have a complete release of one
paper the
title and the url are on the screen
where there is a working paper and
the complete julia code and by the way
an underlying julia package so that
we've released everything and
one complete implementation has been
done in julia so this is going to be our
strategy going forward that one by one
we are engaged in moving our applied
statistics workflow into julia and
solving many of the bottlenecks that
come along along the way
so to give you a flavor of who we are
and what we have been doing uh there are
names of key persons on this slide and i
want to
give a shout out and credit to many many
students who have been part of this work
it's great the kind of team that has
come together the momentum that has
built up around this development and i
just want to introduce some of the
packages
crow is our attempt at a single
consistent api for a wide variety of
statistical models
nighttime lights is the package for
cleaning and bias correcting
nighttime lights satellite imagery
survey.jl is
a package for working with complex
survey data tsx is a time series class
that will be particularly useful for
finance and macroeconomics but also in
any other area where there is regular or
irregular time series data
and we've also done a bunch of smaller
things we've contributed improvements to
the glm package we've built a low s
we've built a merton kmv model with a
distance to default
so
thank you for having been in this
talk so far uh our urls are on the
screen we'd love to have your interests
and involvement in carrying this work
forward and as i said in this conference
session we now deep dive into many of
these things and we're going to come out
at the other end with a more strategic
panel discussion about julia and
statistics and what works and what
doesn't work and what we can do better
thank you
to this talk on the survey.jl package in
a nutshell we are implementing a package
for complex server analysis in julia
this is based on the r package survey by
thomas lumley we aim to provide a more
efficient computing framework that is
required for the growing sizes of
datasets surveys have become a standard
tool for empirical research and social
sciences they've also become an
important tool in market research in the
industry complex surveys involve
sophisticated techniques such as
stratification clustering unequal
probability sampling or sometimes a
combination of the one of the surveys
that we study at xkdr forum is the
consumer pyramid's household service the
survey is executed since 2014 by the
center for monitoring indian economy
there are 236 000 households in india
that are surveyed thrice a year
income from various sources expenditure
on certain goods and services assets
health indicators etc are measured
our common tasks include producing
summary statistics for instance the
median income for each state for each
month and exploring relationships
between variables such as the ill health
rate and income
as one of the working papers of xkdr has
explored a number of software tools are
available to analyze survey data the
survey package in r is a widely used
open source option professor thomas
lumley of the arc team has developed the
package version 1.0 of survey was
released on 4th february 2003 this means
it has experienced long years of
stability and testing many resources are
also available including a book on how
to analyze complex surveys in r and a
research paper that highlights the
technical details of the package while
the package excels in expressivity it's
not very performant the package is
completely written in r while other
packages use libraries written in c and
c plus thus advancements in the r
ecosystem such as using tables haven't
been incorporated in the package this is
probably because this will require
changing the very foundation of the
package
a julia package can be an efficient
alternative to the r package while
matching it in terms of expressivity
just a line by line translation of the
code from and to julia will result in a
faster program the performance can be
further improved by exploiting the
advancements made in julia through
various packages such as group by and
combining dataframe.js
there have been attempts at implementing
a package for survey analysis in julia i
have mentioned two of these in the
footnote these haven't really
materialized however it shows the
interest on this topic in the community
as mentioned in the introduction we are
building a package in julia for survey
analysis based on the survey package in
our we will keep the api of the package
as similar as possible to the r package
while the internal code will be
completely different it will it will be
in a julian way and exploit features
such as group by and combined we
endeavor to achieve the following we
want to provide all the methods of the
survey package in r but in a more
efficient way
we will provide a documentation that
includes information on transitioning
from r to julia
and that will be illustrated through the
examples that are provided in the survey
package of r
the package will have numerical tests
including the cases that are there in
the r package and finally we will have
the cutting edge features of julia such
as probabilistic programming
that's
a lot for the future right now we have
implemented only a very small set of
functions
mean quantile
total and generalized linear models and
a lot of
stuff can actually be done just on the
basis of these as an organization our
primary objective is to do research we
will use this package to do research and
that ensures seriousness about the
quality of the package and the
correctness of the results obtained
through it
if we obtain a result through it and
that gets published in a paper we will
take full responsibility for that
at the same time we feel that making it
open source is necessary because it
brings transparency if there is any
problem in our research people will be
able to find it out and point it to us
we will be happy with the criticism that
people give us
and perhaps the help that they give us
to improve the package which will
improve our research now i come to the
second part of this talk
i will show you the r and julia code
side by side i'll compare them in terms
of expressivity accuracy and also
perform benchmarks
so on the left you see a julia rebel and
on the right you see an hour session so
now we will load the libraries in r you
would do library survey and in julia you
will say using
survey but with a capital s
we load the sample data sets that are
provided with the package data api loads
the api data set this includes five
data sets and we will use the api strat
data set
in julia it's the same syntax
data parenthesis api and again you have
all the api data sets and we will use
api strat data set for this tutorial
to begin we create something called a
survey design this contains information
about the data set and how
or what kind of sampling was used to
create it for example in this case we
say id equal to tilde 1 meaning that
it's a stratified sample
given a column name instead of one then
it would be the clusters
then it also contains information about
which column contains the weights it can
also be probabilities
uh you can mention either of them and
you can also provide a vector for these
instead of a column
you can see that the syntax in r and
julia is very similar so instead of
telling the column name using a tilde we
are telling it using a colon
so now we demonstrate the survey by
function this can be used to compute
mean quantize and total
in this example we will compute the
average of the api 0 0 score for each
county you see the similar similarity in
the r and the julia syntax
again instead of a tilde we have a colon
we have not yet made these into keyword
arguments we are working on that
but you see that overall the syntax is
quite similar
there are some differences in results
you can see it in the case of orange
county uh the standard error answers are
not exactly matching this is because r
performs a series of corrections on top
of a regular standard error
we have implemented some of these
corrections but not all of them and
perhaps this could be one of the reasons
for the speed but i don't think that
it's the entire story however standard
errors are
essential to survey analysis because
using the techniques such as clustering
and stratification you aim to reduce
this standard error
now we'll come to the final function of
our current package
we'll use the glm function to
find the relationship between api scores
and number of means
you can see the coefficients are nearly
the same
both the intercept and the slope
we do store the other parameters that
are there other than
adjust the intercepts such as the aic
score
the asc score as you see is quite
different between our and julia
this is not a glm that we have built we
are just using the glm.gl package that
exists in julia and we are exploring why
this number is different
now i'll come to the benchmarks to show
the difference between performance in r
and julia
i've used the micro benchmark library in
r and the benchmark tools library in
julia
i will use the same functions that i've
used earlier so the same survey by call
in both r and julia
uh i believe the median time is about
350 times less in julia
but now i will increase the complexity a
bit
instead of just grouping by the county
name i will group by two variables this
is county name and meals it doesn't make
much sense but just to show the
performance i will do that
so julia seems to be a lot faster and it
seems even faster when you're grouping
by multiple variables
uh this is probably to do with the group
buying combined feature
finally i'm going to show you the
benchmark for the survey glm feature
i will use the same call that i had used
earlier in the example
so the svy glm feature for this example
is about 30 times faster in julia
compared to r
i thank you for watching this talk
the survey package is not ready right
now so i'm not going to advise you to
try it out we acknowledge the support
from mit julia labs for this project uh
we thank carlos parada and jose santiago
for the guidance on this project through
google summer of code
and finally we thank ajesha and massam
datta for their very valuable inputs
good afternoon and good evening
and my name is vijay everturi i am the
co-founder at pumas ai a company that
was formed about three years ago
using
julia language as a core ecosystem
and today i'm going to be talking to you
as an applied scientist
i'm not a developer
and i've extensively used multiple
languages
and i am a statistician
but they're different kinds of
statistician
and
i would love the tools that i use
to be my slave and not me being a slave
to the tools so the topic of my
presentation today is about
empowering the statistician
and we we talk about the statistician
the many different kinds
i am the self-trained statistician i am
not a professional statistician and
nowadays
you have
the hobby statisticians especially in
the area era of covert where data was
available and everybody wanted to
analyze
but if you want to think about it
pretty much everyone
has some trait of a statistician within
us
we make decisions on a day-to-day basis
and we
apply those decisions
to provide solutions
whether it is in the home front or in
the work front
but focusing a little bit more on
the scientific aspects
scientists
let's start by understanding and playing
a small game
could i ask you to identify the stats
the statistician in this
on the left
is jack and on the right is joe
jack is a trained clinical
pharmacologist
something somebody like me
who had the opportunity
to
learn
and invent learn and train more in
statistics
and use those statistics
in his day-to-day work
joe on the other hand has a strong
technology background and was trained
professional statistics and applied
mathematics
and
for joe to make a career
he has to work
with other
fields
like people like me
so that
there is the science that is applied
and
the solutions are provided using
statistics
at the end of the day all of us wear
multiple hats
it doesn't matter what domain we come
from we have to work with other domains
to provide solutions that are meaningful
for our clients
and
if you
bring all of this together
the idea is that
you know we all talk about collaboration
different domains need to work together
to bring collaboration
and make
successful
solutions and successful products
let's take an
example if you i'm sure all of you know
about uber
and the way uber became a billion dollar
company
is by using the apis that were generated
by each of these individual products
there was an ecosystem that existed
and this ecosystem provided the
absolutely wonderful apis that allowed
uber to compose them together
and
boom it became a billion dollar industry
right
and on the other hand uber gave it back
uber released its own apis and you see
now uber integrated into let's say you
want to book a table at a restaurant you
just open the for example the open table
app or
you can even if you open google maps you
see the popup for uber you want to go
catch flight united delta you open the
app and you have uber integrated there
so uber has released its own apis which
allow other businesses to succeed
now why am i talking about this
the fundamental core here is that there
is no success without an ecosystem
and there is no ecosystem without
composability
and julia language
is
brilliant
in providing
the composable features of its language
the the packages they all just know just
how to talk to each other
but let's sort of bring this back
into a more understanding why are we
even talking about this
now imagine jack and joe wearing those
different hats
they have
different expertise
and
imagine in the same model of
contributing to a particular
product the product here is a
statistician
right
and we're talking about
each
statistician
wearing multiple different hats
and if each of these hats are able to
provide an ecosystem that allows
that particular individual
to analyze data
then
it will become easy for that
statistician so our goal is to make it
really easy for the statistician in the
making
we are all statisticians
and i know the
professionally strained test
statisticians are going to be really
angry but the truth of the matter is
everybody is analyzing data it is true
that we may be
making a lot of mistakes
it's true that we
the applied
self-trained amateur hobby statisticians
may not be doing it the correct way
but
i think it's it's it's
the job of the ecosystem to provide
the necessary tools and education to be
able to
train
anyone to do the science better
if you look at the first principles of
any domain
and i'm looking at this as a unilateral
principle
every domain has its first principles
and
if you want growth and propagation
the first principles need to be taught
well
and you need to provide the tools
now think of this from a
multi-dimensional approach
you're now talking about first
principles across multiple domains that
need to integrate well
and you need to provide the tools and
education to allow the
the
growth and development of the critical
mass
so the
to empower the statistician which is the
title of the stock we really need to
invest and i think julia stats julia
language has to really invest a lot more
into education
and
tools
we already have
fantastic tools but those tools should
allow
easy usage
and they are easy to use
but bring it to the next level bring it
to the masses
the problem right now is that there are
a lot of hurdles
it's pretty much like an entrapment
right
if
if julia language is a first language
said i am learning
then it's not going to be so convoluted
but we are trying to move an ecosystem
of users from other languages
and when they navi they come into this
world of julia language from for example
are
they're obvious to face some hurdles
and these hurdles are natural
and we need to do our best
to
sort of cut those hurdles out
from a natural perspective we expect
our analytical tools to be organized i'm
a clinical pharmacologist
maybe somebody is an epidemiologist they
will use those tools maybe somebody else
is in another domain they will use this
particular tray
if you look at how these trays are
organized
they're easily discoverable
they're clearly marked with colors
they're numbered
and they're easy to
use perhaps they've been set up for
different kinds of
use cases
this
is the expectation
that if we it doesn't matter which
domain you come from
whether i'm coming from clinical
pharmacology or whether i'm coming from
time series analysis or whether i'm
coming from
uh you know fluid dynamics it doesn't
matter different kinds of anal uh
domains
need to have the tools to perform the
analytics the core tools are important
but we need
the tools at the top that will make it
organized discoverable and easy to
analyze but the challenge right now
has been so far
across the other ecosystems that
these tools have been disorganized and
not accessible
maybe this is too bold a statement to
make but the fact of the matter is we
need
more organization education and tooling
to allow the growth of the critical mass
julia
provides
the opportunity for the growth
it's composable
you can teach
julia as you learn the science you can
teach julia as you learn the math
and
the problem right now is that
it's
especially with the statistics ecosystem
it's a relatively small user base
and the julia way of programming
has an on-ramp so people coming from
other languages
strive to do the julia way of
programming
and
the beautiful part about this community
is the you know scientists are very
helpful especially if you're going to
discourse
they're very very helpful and help you
get along
we need more of this
and
obviously the challenge about time to
first everything i know it's
considerable amounts of improvement that
has happened over the way especially
with
uh the ability to have the uh binary
builders and system images that have
really helped even us at
a company like pumas ai
so there are pros and we need to build
on these pros
and the easiest way to build
is the providing
world-class educational material
we need to document the packages
and train the domain user
and not just the next developer who's
going to use your package
yes you should provide your apis for
other package users to use it
but it really we should focus on the end
user and the end user of your particular
package can be from anywhere
the classic
counter to this is that well they're
developing the packages for free
we need resources to be able to do this
absolutely this is a challenge and
companies
like pumas ai and others are helping
in any and we are ready to help in any
way that's possible
the other thing which i really think is
important is to allow
anyone allow anyone
to
do
and when i say anyone not just a
professional statistician but the
self-trained the amateur or the hobby
statistician to try things out and go
from trying things out
to writing about it to publishing about
it to blog about it
we need more
presence in the community and i think
the tools to to facilitate
going from writing
writing doing a simple analysis to
publishing it online should be
the friction should be close to zero
imagine me having to now learn how to
spin up a server and do an html
blog i mean it's it's beyond ninety
percent of the population
so just want we need we need to make it
easier
and lastly we we should incentivize more
programs to teach julia as a first
language and statistics tool
i think this will happen over time
this is already happening at
the university that i'm involved in and
i am pretty sure there are a lot more
universities that are coming up the
excellent books that are being released
and i think we are on the right path
we are at a very opportune time
and we need to
empower every statistician
and
take it to the next level
we have the opportunity to innovate
completely change the mindset and say
let's build the next generation and
the the crowd will follow us the current
generation will also follow us
so
in closing remarks i would say that
we need to strive to empower every
statistician whether they're completely
professional statistician or
self-trained like i am i think at that
if we can achieve that
that is what will allow the growth of
the julia statistics ecosystem
thank you and i hope to hear back from
all of you bye
very much for giving me the opportunity
to speak in julia on
in this talk i am going to talk about
crow a new package a single api for
diverse statistical models
many statistical models can be trained
in julia and diversity of the model
ecosystem is deadly improving
drawing inspiration from
zelic package
from the our world
the cro package gives a simple and
consistent api to the end user
the end user faces the fixed cost of
getting a hang of this once and after
that a wide array of models and
associated capabilities become available
with a consistent syntax
under the umbrella of cro
we hope
others developing statistical models
will build within this framework
let us consider a simple linear
regression
so
we can
we are considering this md cars data set
um where
mpg is miles per gallon
hp is the horsepower
as of you know of a car and wt is the
weight of the
car and i want to predict miles per
gallon as a function of horsepower and
weight
plus some error terms where error
follows normal zero sigma square
unlike likelihood
model will follow effectively
multivariate normal with alpha naught
plus x beta where alpha here is
essentially my beta naught and x beta
will be beta will consist of beta 1 and
beta 2 and x will consist of hp and
weight
so here in this
cr row
we have this simple macro at fit model
which basically
models the mpg
follow hp plus weight
and then
we have taken this data set empty curves
data set from
our data set
so
df contains the
empty cars data set so you provide the
data set and then you just
tell what model class you want to fit
let's say linear regression so you just
say that and then if you run this
it will give you the linear regression
estimates
yeah
so
the intercept coefficient estimated
standard error t value p value and the
95 confidence intervals you can get it
from here
you can get the say bic of the model
if you want you can
find
a ic of the model
you can find say
square of the model
so r squared is
seven percent
so
all standard things are available under
cro stack uh package
now
we did
a
check of the performance gain and in our
we
plot we micro benchmark exactly same
model mpg with hp and weight with this
exactly same data set and it took about
380 microseconds
and on an average
and
when we did the
you know uh
the same thing we checked with the julia
it took about 160 microseconds
and then what we did we also compare it
with the python
um in python there are two packages one
is stat models um which calls the ols
function
and the more popular from one is sk
learned which caused the fit function
and
very interestingly we found that stat
models is very inefficient we don't know
exactly why it is so but learn is taking
about 560 microseconds
whereas r is taking about the
lm which is most popular for fitting a
linear regression for with stats is
taking about 180 microseconds and our
crows fit model is taking about 160
microseconds
so performance is
only one aspect of julia as a
statistician i feel strongest feature of
julia is you can write your own code the
way you write your mathematical
equations and that becomes very useful
when we do bayesian linear regressions
so for
if we want to
model the bayesian linear regression
with say
reach prior which is also known as
conjugate gaussian prior or equivalent
to l2 norm penalty
then all you have to do
just you know
uh
this is your prior if as if it is my on
my board i have to write typically that
okay these are the my hyper prior
parameters
and
v is following inverse gamma h h sigma
following inverse gamma a zero p zero
alpha follow normal
uh
distribution with zero v sigma and beta
follow normal distribution 0 v and y
volume likelihood multivariate normal
with alpha plus x beta comma sigma now
i write these equations on the board the
advantage is in julia this code actually
works and run
so
what we have done in here
that
you don't have to even in
in you can do this in turing you can
literally in the turing.jl package you
can write the way you write in the board
you can write it in the julia and
that runs and
that implement the
hamiltonian monte carlo or quantum monte
carlo and then it gives you the results
for us what we have done we have used
turing
as a uh on as under the over this under
the crow so basically cro is calling
turin to implement the bayesian linear
regression so if you
look at everything else is exactly same
so the model is the
model is mpg following going to fit hp
plus weight
with the data frame
as the
you know where the data is stored and
linear regression so if you don't put
this and this is if you just give this
much
then
what happened is
it follow it fits a simple linear
regression with you know ols method
you see it is fitting a simple linear
regression with ols method
but now
if you
instead of just add
after that add prior reach so
immediately cro would know that okay you
want to fit bayesian linear regression
and with reach prior so it will instead
of fitting calling ols it will call the
hamiltonian monte carlo using turing and
it will run the
model in that way
it took about 0.02 seconds and
now if we run the
so
what we are seeing here is
the parameter statistic so it has by
default it has simulated 10 000 samples
markov chain monte carlo samples these
are the posterior mean and the posterior
standard deviation
and r hat for all the parameters is very
close to 1 so that means the mcmc
has been converged and this is the kind
of 95
credible interval for the coefficients
and the parameters
and
so if you plot the
chains
then
so you can see
that mostly this sigma has converge i
mean you know
it's nicely in the mixing is very good
and
you know
so this is pretty much and all the
beta 1 beta 2 and alphas everything is
there pretty much
all right
so
then what you can do you can fit also
the
lasso penalty on the l1 or sometimes
known as the lapras prior so bayesian
linear regression with the laplace prior
so
everything will be the same like you
know in its i'm taking inverse gamma on
the scale parameters and on the
coefficient instead of normal i am
taking laplace prior
and
rest of the things are pretty much same
so now the changes that you will have
instead of
reach prior you just mention here
laplace prior and that's it pretty much
rest of the things will
just follow the same way
plot the bayesian chain so it's just
like you know
almost all the chains have converged
very nicely
if you go back you can see
that
it's actually
implements the
the during package
if you can see that you know actually it
is calling turing package
and
um
it is actually hmc hamiltonian monte
carlo methods there they're not they're
implementing hamiltonian monte carlo so
the convergence i have seen for even
very quite complicated model
there
it's very stable and
turing is doing
fantastic work in terms of fitting
bayesian models
and we are taking full advantage of
tiering in cro so
you can ask me that if i have turing why
i should call cro so cro is for the
people who are not
well trained in say bayesian computation
but
um
they are like practitioners scientists
applied economist you know and
biostatistician
who are not very well versed with the
bayesian computation who does not want
to write their own bayesian
mcmc or hmc so they want for them some
standard models are being given
we are going to give them a standard
bayesian models as a part of cro so they
just call this like you know fit model
give the model whatever model they want
to fit whatever mod a data set what they
have
whatever model class and whatever prior
they want to use just mention that and
rest of the boom rest of the things will
follow on its way
so that is what
we are thinking
in terms of implementing cro but if you
have a very specialized
model in your mind and you are okay to
write down your code i mean and in
turing and
if you have a very customized model that
you want to build then i think you
cannot have better than
uh turing because i have spent a lot of
time in our stand
and
it's often time a nightmare because
effectively it is a three language
problem
because
first you have to have r on your place
then you have to have c on your place
and stan and these three languages needs
to be you know have the same version
it sometimes you know if you have a
windows have you can have a very
difficult different kind of problems if
you have a you know linux you can have a
very different kind of problems and you
know
and mac will have a different kinds of
problems so you can face very very
different even it comes to
implementation our stand works fantastic
but in terms of speed and implementation
but um
in terms of generic implementations and
can be a bit of a nightmare
compared to that my experience and is
turing is far more seamless just walks
like this
without any hiccups so
i am very recent convert i would say
from our stand to
uh julia turing and we are taking the
full advantage of julia turing in the
sierra
so this is what we are seeing then what
are the least of the models that cro can
solve as of now it can solve linear
regression logistic regression possible
regression and negative binomial
regression
for each of these four models we can
we implement the following methods the
likelihood methods are the often known
as frequentist method among the bayesian
methods you can
implement reach prior or gaussian prior
equivalent to l2 penalty
laplace prior or lasso or l1 penalty
kochi prior t distributed fire and
uniformly distributed prior so these are
the things are
as a part of the current capability of
crow
um
for example if you want to fit say
logistic regression with the logic link
so
from the zelic data set
we are taking the turnout
turnout data set and we are fitting
we're just calling fit model here is the
model vote as a function of age race
income and education
data set name is turnout here you can
see this is the turnout and
we are calling logistic regression with
logic link
so if you just run that
and then
if we just know that
this here is your fit so it's
very this is going this is
what you are seeing is just frequentest
fit of logistic regression
now
if you want
to change your play around with the link
function instead of logit link you can
try profit link
so
all you have to do probe it
you just write it here probe it and
run it you get your
probit link up the implementation if you
want
cauchy
you just change it you get the kochi if
you want
c log
log
and just
and you get the c log log implementation
now
if you want to fit the logistic
regression
with a logic link so you just mention it
here the same model but with reach prior
all you have to do just mention rich
prior here previously you know in the
previous implementation there was no
prior here no prior then it will
implement
um
likelihood methods but if you have
a prior it will implement mcmc method
immediately it will identify that
problem and that okay you are looking to
fit a prior means you are going into the
bayesian version and it will fit a prior
it might take few seconds but
you can see that first of all i will
check for the
r hat
and you can see that all are at very
close to one so that means all the
coefficients has converged
and
you can see the estimates
these are the estimates
and these are the standard deviation of
the posterior standard deviation
and if you plot this thing
you can see that you know
all the chain has converged nicely
mixing is very nice
so currently what are the things that
are under development in for crow
so right now we are implementing linear
discriminant analysis survival analysis
bootstrap inference
hierarchical bayesian models and
gaussian process recreation
it is not possible
for us to implement this
without the
great help from professor allen edelman
and viral shah
and
of course a great team is there
siddhant chaudhary
mawsom ayush ajay and susan all
of them have contributed to the
greatly in from designing the package
from you know
computing from a very basic things
cleaning up
tasting everything was done as a
teamwork
and thank you all thank you very much
welcome to the julia conference
prague gen modern sas and rtlm are two
most popular modules in statistics
and both are in place since last two
decades
jlm in julia is comparatively new
we did some comparative studies in the
beginning of the year 2022.
let us present some of them one by one
two main aspects of the generalized
linear models
are distribution family and link
functions
let's see where julia glm is positioned
right now
except geometric distribution almost all
one parameter exponential distributions
are available in julia
but geometric distribution is the
special case of negative binomial
distribution so one can do modeling with
geometric distribution indirectly
but r and sas both have bigger ecosystem
than generalized linear model
there are many extensions of rs glm
especially zero inflated models and vd
are not available in julia at least a
stable version
the list of link functions is quite
impressive
the one and only missing link function
is power link
the power function defines the class of
transforms that use a power function or
logarithmic function as it is shown here
many existing link functions are a
special case of power link for example
it is identity link when lambda is one
it is square root link when lambda is
0.5
it is log length when lambda is
zero
it is inverse length when lambda is
minus one
it is inverse square link when lambda is
minus two
the benefit of having power link is we
can find optimal lambda value using some
optimization methods
especially some heuristic methods
the example shows here a way to find
optimal value based on bic
one can use any other
method like aic aicc long likelihood etc
to get the same
now let us see how julia glm performs
with some extreme data this is a data
set or table i used to torture the
numerical routines i have written
i have inherited the data set from
professor l wilkinson the author of
grammar of graphics book
if we look at the data carefully we can
observe the tiny observe the relation
between variable x and tiny
variable x can be expressed as
one e to l times of tiny
if we want to perform a linear
regression with intercept where x is a
dependent variable and tiny is the
independent variable like x equal to a
plus b times tiny
then we should have zero as the estimate
of a and one e12 as the estimate of b
unfortunately julia lm produces
something else
whereas r produces correct one
now let us extract model matrix m in
response vector y and calculate m prime
m inverse times m prime y
these matrix operation give estimates of
linear model
these estimates are correct
julia glm uses joel ski decomposition
which is very fast compared to qr
decomposition or svdg composition
but less accurate
especially for ill-conditioned data
okay for huge variable both r and julia
glm calculate same and estimate
correctly
nest national institute of standards and
technology archived a set of 11 data
sets with corresponding linear model and
certified estimates
this claim that certified values are
accurate in last decimal places
we have tested both r and jury lm
functions with these datasets
now let us take one from the list which
is
no int one a data set where
corresponding model does not have any
intercept term
we can see both r and julia produce same
estimates
and the estimates are matched with the
certified value
in case of r squared r matches with
certified value
but julia unfortunately produces a
negative value
this has been corrected in the latest
release v1 version 1.8
now let us compare the performance
to have an idea about the performance of
julia glm we have performed a logistic
regression with 50 independent variables
and approximately 3.5 million rows
we have tested the performance in linux
linux machine with these configurations
based on 20 evaluations the median time
for julia
is approximately 5 times faster than the
median time for r
this is not only because of cholesky
decomposition but julia glm utilizes
maximum possible resources
as we all know the computational
backbone of julia is very strong
the following are contributions to julia
glm
we have added power link function and
geometric distribution we have corrected
some functionality in glm
for our models with no intercept so that
it produces correct metric like r square
we have also tried to improve
readability of glm documentation
right now multicollinearity is handled
only in lm function using the keyword
argument drop collinear
still glm function throws an error if
there is multicollinearity in the
dataset
we have a step full request to
incorporate drop co-linear feature in
glm function like lm function
we are grateful to the julia start
community
especially to mr milan
for making these pr's successes
hello
a very good evening to everyone
my name is
and i'm going to talk about
tsx which is a new package to deal with
tank series data in julia
so why another package
when we moved from
the our world to
using julia to solve our problems in
finance we encountered a few issues
we found out that the
syntax to use
time series
operations wasn't very convenient or
natural
we have been users of zoo and xgs in our
for many years and have used it to solve
various kinds of complex problems and we
believe that is the
correct idiom
to solve tank three specific problems
those interfaces just feel natural
then
we
saw that a lot of these time series
packages have custom data structures and
hence
a lot of code
has been written to solve the same
problem
which is not really consistent across
all the packages because the data
structures are different
and hence it is as
difficult to maintain
if you look at the entire ecosystem it's
not very efficient to have different
packages solving the same problem
and
they need a lot of coding effort to
maintain
then uh
we found
it challenging to deal with
heterogeneous data in the same table
these days
one data set contains everything from
float to integers to categorical
variables
it is not
that one table contains only one type of
data
so these were the challenges uh which we
faced and
this is the reason why we thought of
starting a new package
so what were the design goals of
tsx
well so
first and foremost we
wanted to utilize an existing widely
used and well tested package
to
promote code reuse and avoid duplication
of
coding effort
this also results in easier maintenance
then we wanted to
handle heterogeneous
types in time series data in one
table
more easily
of course uh as i mentioned earlier we
wanted the package to have a more
convenient
and intuitive syntax to deal with time
series operations
then
another design goal of tsx was to
enable and allow
custom index types multiple types of
index
which is that
the package should allow integer indexes
it should allow date indexes it should
allow date and time indexes and so forth
so this is something which we
did not
we
did not find
and uh a shout out to uh ahem zilus's
zoo package and uh the xts package nr
because
we learned a lot from these packages
and we have used those learnings to
build tsx
so after looking
at
our design goals
and
using all the packages doing a lot of
research and experimentations
with the existing time series packages
in julia we settled down at this data
structure
as you can see the primary data
structure it's called ts and there is
only one property of this structure its
core data which is nothing but a data
frame
we settled on
using data frame at the core of tsx
because data frames dot jl is one of the
most
widely used mature packages out there
it's well tested and provides all the
functionality which is probably needed
for doing all kinds of time series
operations
the only thing is that the data frames
interfaces are not very convenient to do
time series operations
so
with tsx what we aim to do
and what we have done is to
build
wrappers
on top of
data frames
methods
these wrappers are easy to use
for doing time series operations
using dataframes.jl has
other set of advantages as i mentioned
it's well tested
it's used by a lot of people so bugs
are reported more often and there's a
big community around it and they though
these bugs also get fixed quickly
then
because
a lot of functionality is already built
and the community is already maintaining
it
the
it
is easier it will be easier to maintain
tsx because of this reason
most of the methods which are written in
tsx are just a few lines of code
just because data frames already
provides that functionality
after deciding to use data frame at the
core of uh ts struct we decided to keep
the index of
the data
as the first
column of the data frame itself
so during construction of the ts object
the data is sorted using the index
column
how to use this uh is what i will be
covering uh in the later slides
so the reason why the index was kept as
a column inside the data frame
was because it is much more convenient
to use data frame or transformation data
transformation operations if the
index is part of the data frame as
another column
as i mentioned we've written a wrapper
functions over
data frame
transformation methods
and which provide a convenient syntax
for time series operations
all the functionality provided by
dataframes.jl comes for free
including the performance and robustness
then
another feature of tsx is that it
provides easy conversion between
ts objects and data frame
which enables use of
functionality provided by many different
packages because data frames is
really
used by a lot of
packages
and any package which supports
operations on a data frame will support
operations on ts object also
then the other advantages
another advantage of using data frame is
that
handling of missing data comes by
default because data frame already
handles it
so the basic constructor of a ts object
is
just uses
a data frame as the first argument the
first column of the data frame
is assumed to be
the index of the data
if it is different then
it can be provided as the second
argument
so
the second easiest way to construct a ts
object is to use
an array
here we have uh created a
date range
uh from 1 of january 2017 to 10th of
january 2017 there are 10 dates and we
are generating some uh
10 random numbers
the first argument is the
is the
array of random numbers and the second
argument is the date range and you can
create a ds object using this
then this is the most widely used use
case of reading csv files
now as you will see
this
is
quite easy
it's quite easy to use
to read in a csv file and create a ds
object out of it
again this functionality comes for free
because there is already a sink for
a data frame
in the csv package
and because ts
structure only has data frame
as its only property
so it's
easy to convert from data frame to a ts
object
so these are some of the methods which
are supported correctly on ds objects
because this is a
new package
there is very basic functionality which
is available but it works
so we have the apply function which can
be used to apply a function
on your data
uh
and if it which can be grouped over or
time period
then we have a function to apply another
function
over rolling window
of specified size
then we have a function to
join or
columbine
two different ts objects
into a single object using index as the
key
then we have bcat or row bind operation
which can combine two ts objects row
wise while matching column names
then we have diff which can be used to
compute discrete differences over
successive row elements
we have
log to compute logarithm
lag and lead to compute lagging and
leading series
we have a basic plot function which
plots
the time series
table with index on the x axis
now we look at three problems from the
finance world
we use
daily stock returns data and perform
some operations on it
we perform the exchange data regression
and then we
handle intraday data all using the tsx
package
so the first step
for problem number one
is that we download data from yahoo
finance using the market data package
here we are downloading
data for two
symbols so one is a
stock called itc and other is
the nifty index
we
download this data and then convert it
into data frame and then do ds object
market data returns a time array object
so
which cannot be directly converted into
a ds object as of yet
in the future
we should have that functionality
as you can see uh the data set
the first column is the index
which has
been automatically converted by
ts
and then we have the the values open
high low close adjusted close and the
volume
the
second step uh to this is to join
closing prices of
both the series we are interested in
adjusted close
and what we do is to take the
uh
intersection of uh the index of both the
series and create one data set uh one
table out of this
because the
join operation
[Music]
created different names we have to
rename uh the columns
uh to their original symbol name so that
we can use them
conveniently later on
so
this is how the data now look looks like
so we have two columns
itc and nifty and
the index contains all the dates for
which
the
dates of which data was present in both
the both the symbols
both the securities
the next step is to
fill in missing values which may have
existed
in the original data set or may have
been introduced after doing the
c bind or the join operation
we use impute.locf
from the impute.jl package to perform
this operation
since impute.locf doesn't directly work
on ts objects yet
we are using the data property
of the ts object
which
is the data frame which is the
underlying data frame we take the
underlying data frame we pass it into
pipe it into compute.locsf
which
which fills in the missing values and
then we convert it back into a ts object
as you can see the
output of the describe function there
are no missing values
left the next step is to convert
the series into weekly
frequency for this we are using the
apply operation this is pretty easy
the first argument is the ds object
itself the second argument is the period
which is the subtype of the dates dot
period structure
or the date start period type
the third argument is the function to
apply to each group belonging to the
same frequency here we are using last so
this
apply will pick up the last observation
from each week
the fourth obser the fourth argument is
also a function
which is for the indexing operation
which specifies the index value to use
for the
for the single value which has been
taken from the group
as you can see in the output
the last value has been
taken and the last index value has also
been taken from each
group belonging to the same week
so you can see the index they are
a week apart
the next step is to compute
log returns
which we do easily again by using the
log function and then doing a diff over
it
and as you can see
the log returns have been computed for
both the series
while maintaining the index
now we want to
run a simple
market model regression
wherein
there's the first step which
we create a formula
where we have the
response variable as the stock itc and
we have
the nifty index as the predictor
so we create the formula and then we use
the lm function from
glm.jl package
to run this regression
again
the lm function works on a table
format
which is provided by data frame
so we can directly use the code data
property of the ts object to run this
regression easily
we put in the
formula as the first argument and
ts returns code data as a second
argument and these are the results of
the regression with the
with the coefficients the standard error
and the 95 percent confidence bands
the next
problem is the exchange rate regression
so here
some of the steps are similar to what we
have done earlier
for example we will be downloading the
daily data for
the currency pairs we will be converting
the series into weekly closed data
and
fill in the missing values then we will
create log returns
and do a simple regression
the next step will be to do a rolling
window regression with a window width of
100 weeks
and then we extract the moving window
values of a currency pair
coefficient and
can compute the residual standard
deviation
then we plot the results of this rolling
window estimates
again we use a market data
function to download data from
yahoo finance
we download five currency pairs
then
in the second output you can see the
structure of one of these currency pairs
there is an index the data starts from
2033
till 2022.
second step is to
join this data
join all the currency pairs into one
object
and we again use the adjusted closing
prices
here we are using the inner join
function
from the data frames package because tsx
currently
the join operation in tsx currently
doesn't support joining more than two ts
objects
but
the join operation of tsx uses
this data from frame function only
so this is the output when we combine
all the five currency pairs into one
again we have a data from 2003 till 22
and we have five columns
uh we rename these columns because after
the join operation they have been
changed
then we convert this
object of adjusted closing prices into
weekly data
after filling in the missing values
this is again a
simple operation of using code data
using the data frame of the ts object
and putting it into
compute.locf and then converting it back
into ts object
once we have the missing values filled
we
use apply again like we did it in the
previous problem to
convert this into weekly data and take
the last observation
the step is to
compute
the log returns again similar
we do a diff log of the weekly closing
prices and
we
rename it and this is how the final data
set looks like
now we compute rolling means with a
window size of 200
we use the function roll apply
we use the statistics dot mean function
applied to the
returns object
and the inr chf column and the final the
last argument is the window size
and this is the result
of that of this operation
the next step is to apply a rolling
regression with a window size of 200
wherein
what we need to do is to create a
function because we want to
use all the
all the currency pairs as the
predictors here
so
we want to
write this function so the formula
contains inr chf as the response
variable and all the
remaining four
now what we wanted to do really was to
do a role apply
apply of this function on this object
and just provide the window
window size
but
change rolling functions or jail
which may or may not be possible
or develop something from scratch or use
some other package but this is this
feature is on tsx roadmap
this is an important feature to have in
a time series package because this is a
very common finance problem
so we will eventually
have this
in the package
now we come to our third problem of
handling intraday data
here we use
two csv files to read an intraday data
which is at a millisecond level
this is simulated data because we did
not have access to real intraday data
this is the structure there is the
index we have the price
as the second column and then we have
the quantity
we have converted both these
data sets into ts
objects now the first step is to convert
them into 15 second observations
for this we again use the apply function
but in the second argument
we supply the second which is a
type defined in the dates package
but we supply it with the
15 as the
parameter which means every 15 second
like 15 seconds is what second
parenthesis 15 means
in apply it means
that the data will be grouped
for
15 seconds after every 15 second each
group will contain
15 seconds worth of observations all the
observations which have happened in
those 15 seconds
the third argument is the
function which we provide to pick the
observations in each group
here again we are providing last it will
pick the last observation
of the 15 second
of each 15 second group
the last argument is index at which
decides the value to be used in the
index
for the value which has been picked up
from the group
here
what we are doing is that we are taking
the last
second of the observation because our
data is at millisecond level but now we
are converting it into second level so
the index
values should be at the second level and
the last
argument this is the function this is
what it does
i'm sure there are better ways to do it
and we will work on this
to make it much more convenient and this
is slightly more
complicated
expression to achieve this
now we create a single
ds object using the join operation
we take the price prices of both the
securities and combine them together
here
the third argument to join is join all
which means take the union of the
indexes in both the securities earlier
we have seen join both which is the
intersection
of the indexes
this is how the data set now looks like
after doing the join and we rename the
columns price underscore last and price
underscore last underscore 1
to itc and nifty
which are the symbol names
now we compute the returns
again the same formula of doing a diff
on the log of the ts
this gives us the log returns
now we plot the squared returns we use
the plots package
on the x axis we have converted the date
time into time
and on the y-axis we have the squared
returns of nifty
this is the regression bar plot
here we have first
removed all the rows which contained
missing
using impute.filter again impute.filter
doesn't
yet work on ts object but it returns it
works on data frames so we are using
returns.code data the codata property
and
we have specified dimension as the rows
the output of
impute dot filter has been converted
into ts object
second step we compute
we run a regression with
itc
as the response variable and nifty as
the predictor
we again use the code data property to
run this regression we do a bar plot of
the
with
index on the x axis and the
squared residuals on the y axis
so this was it as far as usage of tsx is
concerned
i hope you have been able to understand
and you do find value in using this
package
now as far as the development room dial
is concerned as i mentioned this is a
fairly new package and a lot of things
need to be developed
some basic functionality exists
but
for example there are certain important
things which still need to be worked on
the first things is to implement tables
or jl interfaces for better inter opera
operability then we want to do feature
parity with zoo and xgs from r
integration with impute.jl
we are right now converting the ds
object into data frame then running
compute and then converting it back into
ts which is quite inefficient
we want to introduce metadata support
again we will be using
the metadata support which
is in works with in the data frames
package
then we want to support rolling
regressions we want to support custom
index types
and not only limited
right now
as it is right now to only integers and
time type
type
then we want to improve test coverage
to make the package much more robust
we want to support duplicate index
values some people on the
on discourse and on
github have commented
on other packages that they are looking
for this feature
we want to support
better we want to provide better support
for missing values
we want to introduce broadcasting
operators some of the work is already
being done on this
then
we are thinking of certain optimizations
for regular and irregular time series
and of course
we
will be doing bug fixing and performance
improvements as we go along
and a big thank you
to julia lab at mit for financial
support for this project it wouldn't
have been possible
without them carlos parada for guiding
with julia summer of code and google
summer of code we have some students who
are working with us
and
these are the contributors who have
helped us in
by writing code by doing endless
discussions on the design
and on the package on package features
and helping with real-world problems
so that the package is useful
so thank you
hello everyone welcome to this
conversation
on how we will make progress on
julia and statistics
we've got
a bunch of remarkable people here on
this call
in the metadata of this video you will
see their profiles and
i would like to get started with the
substantive
conversation so our first question
what is our assessment
of
the strengths and weaknesses of
junior as a foundation for doing
statistics not the state of statistics
in julia but rather that
if we apply in our minds eye if we think
some time into the future when a lot of
things are fixed up what's the
opportunity what's the potential
how do we see this evolving that in what
ways are we
attracted that there is something good
and important here which can make our
life and statistical programming better
so can i
first ask you for
what is it that makes you feel good
about doing statistics programming in
julia
professor bates can i please turn to you
yeah i
of course
feel very strongly about avoiding the
two language problems you know my
background i i worked for a long time on
the mixed effects modeling and r
and had to write either an r and c
or
r
c plus plus and rcpp and rcpp eigen and
trying to bring in sparse matrices and
all of that sort of stuff so
it just became too difficult you're
juggling too many
different uh interfaces different
languages
so when julia came along when i first
heard about it it was just sort of they
can do that
and i became very enthusiastic right
away
so i think that that's
the basic value
that julia brings to people doing
statistical computing is the same that
it brings to a lot of people in
technical computing areas
that you can
get the performance of the low-level
compiled language
while working in a high level
dynamically typed language
that's from the developer's point of
view from the user's point of view
it's oh this can be done
you know i
switched to assessing variability
parameter estimates in some models just
by using a parametric bootstrap
and why because i can fit these models
over and over again tens of thousands of
times and do that in a very short period
of time
so
it's also
um
composability the package system the
sort of
zen of developing
julia package is
much more
disciplined
you know it's expected that you're going
to have continuous immigration it's
expected that you're going to
have you know test driven development
and so on
so all of those aspects
make it
attractive
for long-term prospects
the difficulty is that
you have to
convince people that it's worthwhile
learning something new
and
that's always an impediment
you have to provide some sort of
short-term
benefit
which sometimes can be just oh this
package exists there
which is where i think that the
interface packages you know are called
pie called julia call from either of
those
is is useful because it allows people to
you know dabble their feet in the water
and
learn a little bit about the language
i'm still at the point where
when i do some analyses i fall back on
our through our call for for doing the
plots you know i i love what people are
doing in mocking i love the work on
algebra graphics i'm better at using
once we're gg plotting
so
when you need to get something done
uh having a familiar tool is very
important too
so
i i see the long-term benefits as just
it's a very
solid language it's a language that's
built on a very good foundation
but it's still being built so you don't
have all of the nice truths and
towers
in the language at present
and that's going to
appeal to a type of user who's more on
the developer end than on the strip i
got to get this report out by three
o'clock and i don't have time to
learn everything that i need to know
before then
um
let me pass that
to somebody else
so yeah i
i think i agree with all that although
one thing that i do want to note that
like i think makes julia such a sort of
an amazing foundation is just even for
people who
uh
especially i guess for people who are
who wouldn't have to learn something new
because they don't uh have something old
that they already know um so people
uh like for instance i would probably
not be a developer or working on
statistics or programming at all if it
weren't for uh
for julia uh because this is actually
it's like a
uh i am usually the kind of person who
was a lot more interested in uh
statistics or mathematics or
uh applied modeling than i am and
actually uh
in actually coding and i do not know
actually a lower level language like c
plus or uh something like that uh and
then just being able to spray like right
away get uh straight into julia and
immediately be able to to write like i'm
used to in python or uh or something
simple like that and have it
uh be actually like usable for a
uh for a package that i want to build
instead of having to learn a completely
new languages honestly it's uh
amazing and i think that that's a great
advantage of julia that we can get
people in
so quickly and help them
[Music]
uh get contributing to the packaged
communities so easily went in
in the python community or the r
community you would have to spend god
knows how long first learning uh c plus
plus
sorry
grew up in the r world what has been
your experience in the transition
uh yeah i grew up in the world and so i
just started learning julia in jan 2022
so i'm just baby in that sense i'm six
months old in terms of julia world
so
uh what i found astonishing i mean speed
is definitely because it's a
you know
native
language i mean you're writing you don't
have to worry about the two language
problem as presidents mentioned
so speed is definitely something but
what
uh
really you know surprised me
when i started using turing.js
um
like the way i can write the code like
you know i can
uh when the way i teach bayesian
statistics in class
effectively whatever i'm writing on the
board in the blackboard
that directly goes into my code and that
runs
and that was like wow
i mean if i chose this to my students
they will be like
i mean the way you write mathematics
that can be codified and that can run
and give you the results
that is what actually
uh
like make me really really
uh interested about julia
and i
hope that going forward the package i
would like to develop
will be have all those features of
turing.shell
because
you know that is something
it's abstract but it's absolutely
beautiful because
the way you write mathematics you can
codify that in
is something is just beyond me
so uh yeah speed
you know
i mean
maybe
10 years down the lane there could be
another language which will build julia
i mean then there will be maybe in 20
years down the line there will be
quantum laptop
i mean there is no end in the speed i
mean and we know this game
but
the thing that really surprises me
is that the way you can write
the you can code the language that's
that's really surprised me and you know
i'm all immersed in julia for my last
six months
would you tell us your thought process
and decisions around this
yeah so uh
first of all thank you for this i you
one of the most important things that
the two aspects i have i have two hats i
have an academic hat and i also develop
products that are commercially sold in
junior so i want to give you both
perspectives um i've been teaching our
and
as an i'm not a developer i've never
been trained in any programming language
but i've been teaching r for
statistics um and
everything that is related in pharma for
the last almost 12 years right
and
back in 2016 or 17 i i came across a
problem
where i am not making it up i had to use
a mix of python
pearl
fortran
and r
which i spent about eight months
working on
and that turned out when i actually
discovered julia
and i used i think at that point julia
tb which is still there i ended up doing
that entire project
in one language in literally two months
right and that has that opened up a lot
for me
right so that was more from a research
perspective and then i realized man if i
could actually make this happen
for people like me in the industry this
would be great and that's how you know
the whole productization of what i'm
doing happen right
but from an academic perspective i
completely agree with uh
saaresh and the fact that you codify the
mathematics that you write and you're
able to teach
has that's a completely beautiful thing
because then it's it's simple what you
write is what you see you know it's like
the editor what you write is what you
get kind of you know what you write is
what you see and that actually uh uh
made things a lot more simpler and that
goes to the next point of actually what
uh
professor bates just mentioned that
it's important to teach
and how you teach you know what carlos
also said it's
imagine teaching somebody who's already
learnt r
for a long time versus somebody who's
coming in new i think for the newer
generation of population it's so much
more
easier to teach statistics
if you are in this
interface then if you have to go through
a simple kind of interface where you
have to write everything else so there's
a little bit of a
there's a beauty plus brains kind of
thing that's going on here in my opinion
uh
pokemon do you want to jump into this
yes so i was thinking what to add
and
because there were many topics already
covered but
i would say that
what is important especially important
in terms of statistics is
one thing that
i just mentioned but also it was
it could be have errors that
julia's strengths become
apparent when you start to need to do
something longer than you know 30 or 50
lines of script
so once you really need to develop a
solution that is it's really a bigger
project not just a toy example you know
that you do on your class assignment
then you can see that the
way judea
in a sense gives you tools but also
forces you to structure your thinking
and allows you to be more productive in
the long run and
this more productive of course part of
it is
performance but
i would say it's also just developer or
you know statistics in in the context of
our discussion
performance in terms of how much you can
pull off in i don't know one week or one
month
and
i know python i know are i know
everything
you know all those standard
programming languages
as
many of you also mentioned every one of
us work with different languages but
when i start a new project and i ask
myself which tool should i use
to spend at least time to get the result
then i
recently i always choose julia
so
because
i end up for example deciding that what
base julia offers not even speaking
about the packages but what base julia
offers is like a perfect mix
of
basic functionalities that you need to
build algorithms
around working with
array like data
and this is something you don't have in
python you don't have it in r of course
they have functionalities
that allow you to work with others but
this is all always skill it's like kind
of add-on to the language actually in
python it's another
in our it's in build but it's not
convenient in julia simply
the set of choices even in base julia
that was made
makes it easy to develop
new things
or i would say in general to implement
algorithms
but
and the thing is that the biggest
benefits of it you see
when you need to do something bigger
because
at least this is my perspective that
if i need to do just you know
reading the data and create a
correlation matrix then probably
there is no big difference in which
language you implemented but
once you start
building something larger especially
that has to go to production later
then the benefits of julia i think
are quite significant
one thing i
would like to add to professor
what he just said
about performance i totally agree uh
with him and having worked with
r for many years i mean i have no
formal training in statistics my
background is computer science uh so i
have uh used uh
i transitioned into art it was a long
learning curve to think about vectors
and matrices matrices as uh
as the base on which objects on which to
perform and then when again a little
learning curve to migrate into julia
as sorry said i'm also like a
six-month-old inventor in this
this ecosystem
but what i did notice is uh in terms of
um let's say performance
is that julia makes you think about uh
performance of your code
uh inherently i mean it's it's there
it's built like that
for example in r uh i learned that over
the years that there are
things which you uh
you learn so
the memory you know the garbage
collection about the memory copy and
write you're working with data frames
you change one column another data frame
gets created and how the garbage
collection works
so all those things which you learn over
the years but here in julia what i saw
is that
the
even uh the julia documentation mentions
it very clearly even the generic
interfaces are built like that to
support in place
uh
modifications of an object for example
that is something which i just
loved about the about the language that
the standards are in place
to have that performance thinking and of
course thinking about the types that's
inherently again built
within the language
yeah but here for example if you mention
this this is something
i a maintainer of data frames there i
always have a challenge with this what i
mean by this is that
we indeed expose you know various
possibilities because you can copy data
not copy data and you can you have full
control of what you can do but
on the other hand i always think
okay so for expert this is very good but
the question is
and maybe you can comment you know when
you were
doing the transition from r
isn't it creating a kind of
steep learning curve that user comes and
sees i have so many options
i don't know even if i need them
so why do i need to learn them
so
i i guess
for me it was a little easier because i
had faced those problems and at one
point point uh there was one project
where
i was working and it was handling some
100 millions of transaction a day that
kind of data and then
you had to think about these issues
the data wouldn't fit into the computer
ram and then you have like multiple
computers you would
you know offload the computation to
different machines and then your program
crashes
out of memory and then you're thinking
okay
what is happening why is it happening
right so and those
that experience i felt uh sort of helped
me
i but i do think it could be confusing
for somebody who's not
seen this problem or had not had this
problem or think about it
so
yeah i mean
i can think that okay why do i need to
modify the object in case like i create
copies right
so that is obviously there
can i say go into a next block of
discussion uh this is about the tension
between building a julia statistics
ecosystem that
speaks more native julia that is rooted
in julia idiom that is rooted in the
model computer science that is in julia
versus
the objective of easing the transition
path for people who are coming from our
or coming from python and are looking
for something more familiar okay there
will always
be that tension and you know how should
we approach
this uh question
what are what are the right ways to make
those trade-offs uh bogomill
you have often talked about the question
of missing data
i feel that in the field of statistics
we've really got to have
transparent
standard default handling of missing
data all the time
by the underlying tools without
requiring overhead on the part of the
user because handling missing data in a
certain sensible way as is done in our
should really be in the infrastructure
of a statistical programming system so i
can see how
it was important for julia to implement
missing data in a certain way and there
are domains where missing data is viewed
differently but for us as statisticians
observations that have missing data is
just completely normal and
is a part of our bread and butter so how
should we build a world of
statistics and
language syntax
and packages
which are good for the julia statistics
world and then how should we deal with
this tension
between the old user base of r and
python versus what is cool and elegant
and
high quality what we can pay for the
next generation in julia while leaving
some of the old users behind sometimes
yes so if we mention
new things let me just comment on
two examples of the tensions that we
have here so for example
by default
julia collections like vectors do not
allow basic values unless you tell julia
that he wants to allow them
so what is the reason for this
there are
there are three kinds of reasons first
reason is that as a user you can
explicitly say i don't want to allow
missing and if someone tries to put a
missing into this vector i want an error
because i expect this as a contract not
to allow me things and i think it's
quite often useful
to have this constraint because then you
have a
quick fail of your computations the
second aspect
is performance so not allowing missing
values in vectors
gives you a bit better performance not a
big difference but there is a small
benefit of not having missing values for
your computations
third thing is that if you have a vector
that doesn't allow
missing values by default this vector
uses less memory
so in a sense you have
a situation where
you
not allowing missing values uses less
memory is a bit more performant and
sometimes it's wanted but on the other
hand as you have said in statistics
because in other fields like engineering
you very often don't even need missing
values so then people say this is
exactly the choice that we want but in
statistics this is a opposite from the
perspective that
most often you would have those missing
values
and then you can have to constantly
think of
how to handle them
and the second
so this is kind of low level
consideration
and the second aspect is for example
treating missings and conditions so for
example so what i mean by this
most users when they say i want to
filter for example data frame by some
condition
intuitively think that missing values
should be dropped
when filtering
while in judea it will be an error if
you encounter missing value because you
will learn that
missing is not a
boolean condition
but the now you can
think okay but why do we have it the
answer is because sometimes
actually you want for example missing to
be treated as true not as false
so you say okay if i have anything i do
not want it to be dropped by default so
here we have a kind of tension that
there is some behavior like dropping
missings when you filter
some collection
which is 90 percent of cases correct
but 10 percent of times is exactly not
what you want so if it happens by
default then you get the wrong result
but on the other hand and this is what
we have in judea at least by default is
that you have to be explicit how you
want to handle missing values but this
gives an additional
mental burden that in your code you have
to
do an explicit handling of missing for
example using collesk so you say call us
x either true and false and then you are
happy with the condition but you have to
be explicit
while normally people would just write a
condition and expect that missing would
be dropped so this is a kind of thing
that
[Music]
again
i am very used to using julia so it's
not a problem for me when i uh when i
write my code but i am always thinking
okay if newcomers don't find it too
demanding to constantly have to think of
how to handle missing instead of having
the default that is most of the time
correct
and i'm not sure which is the best way
here
i would contrast
the way that julia handles missing data
with the way that r handles missing data
and
r
was derived from an earlier language
called s and s was specifically designed
to
be working on data science
statistical sorts of applications
and
they made a decision
to incorporate missing data at a very
low level
so
all of the
vector types in r
have
a missing data sentinel
and it's like one of the man values for
floating point and it's the
minimum
uh
negative value for integers and so forth
but what that means is that every time
that you process
a vector
you have to
have the loop in there to check for the
missing value sentinel
and
you know that's just not going to fly
until
because
julia
is used by people who don't have missing
data and who are not willing to allow
that that kind of performance here
um
so
yes
r does it in such a way that it's very
convenient and
low
mental overhead for
working with missing data but it comes
with a performance penalty and i think
that
in in my experience it's not too much to
expect people to think more about how
they work with missing data
if the benefit is performance
but can i take us back to the more
abstract discussion how should we think
about the tension between
building things in a native way
versus
building things that are more
accessible and recognizable to people
coming in from our and from
python um
can you describe your experience
in building the survey package
the tension between building something
that's clean and nice in julia versus
building something that looks more like
thomas lovely's beautiful survey package
in our
uh yeah so and go go mail is also uh in
an issue pointed it out that
maybe it's a better idea to do it in a
more julia way
but
yeah i just felt that there's so many
resources available by professor langley
the first version was released in 2000 i
mean version 1.0 was released in 2003
and since then there have been so many
documents so many talks
uh books and so on on the package and
there are examples there are discussions
on our help and uh static stats towards
stack exchange so it's just that the
resources are so widely available that i
feel that
the transition will be very smooth if
the syntax is similar
and uh also from my own perspective of
uh as a developer it's a bit easier
uh and so so there's a quote by uh
thomas lumley that
we don't care about speed in the package
and we only care about expressivity so
he is really focused on expressivity
and internally he has sacrificed speed
and he has said that don't
there's no need to
fix it until someone really starts
complaining and because data is getting
bigger and bigger now so we are
complaining now but simply moving it to
julia has increased the speed by
more than 100 times and actually
internally it's different so for example
uh i think he's not using group by and
combine that effectively and because
it's so well done in uh data frames so
internally the code is very simple
there's like some group by and some
combine it's it's a lot faster if i were
to use a direct translation and do a
search operation then it would be a lot
slower so internally it's not a direct
translation it's a it's written in a
julia way but it's just that the api
is very similar to the rfp it's not
exactly the same because i can't do it
but it's very similar and i've kept it
like that so that people can transition
[Music]
so i have a point uh just to
piggyback on irish's thing right so the
question here is um what are we trying
to achieve in developing the julia stats
ecosystem are we
we're not trying to compete against arm
we're trying to build a new ecosystem
and an ecosystem that is here to stay
it's okay
for people to use multiple languages
people will always use multiple
languages i think that's a realization
that i've come across when having trying
to put a product out there that's
competing against a 60 year old uh
elephant
that's there and you know
i know what doug bates is laughing but
he knows exactly what i'm talking about
right it's it's been developed in 1965
70
and the entire pharma community is still
using fortran 77 and 4chan 90.
right so
it's okay for people to use other tools
but i think what it is what is really
happening is
in in my opinion if i if if i was trying
to be in a governance system for this
i wouldn't try to replicate what's out
there
but
i would instead invest the efforts
into increasing the resources the
education around this i will tell you
you know still 2009 2010
if you look at the growth of r it was
it was okay it was growing up it was not
crazy people were still using sas a lot
it was only after our studios
uh platform launched and they had the
simple knitter and published to our pubs
came
people started realizing that hey you
know what i can write something and hit
publish and my article can go online
they don't have to know anything about
coding
about html about websites
and now everybody became a hobby
statistician
everybody became a hobby blogger
everybody became a hobby trainer and
that is what
we don't have in julia yet i mean i'm
sure the packages are there but it has
not become that prevalent
and i think our focus should be on
developing the best tools
not worry about pulling people from
other tools as long as we have enough
good educational material
i would rather go for that than trying
to pull people from us because you can't
change people's habits if i'm used to
brushing my teeth after having my
breakfast
you can't force me to have my breakfast
and then brush my teeth right it's just
the way it is right so that's i think
it's just going to
evolve over a period of time uh so one
thing i want to add so you ask why are
we developing this
so actually i mean the real reason why i
first started writing that code was for
an internal thing so we use a very large
survey data set
and
it was a huge it is a usual site in our
office to see people start a code and
then leave their laptop a little open
for like five six hours so
uh and then i did it once it was the
first time i was using that data set and
i
just could not believe that it was
taking so long so
so it was actually for me and for like
our team that we started doing it
and then uh even even though i've made
the court so similar to are they still
not moved from
uh from our so
it's actually just me who is using it
right now but that that was actually the
purpose of making the package well i
understand all of us i was using that as
a context to say that i think a focus
should be on education and develop the
tool in the right way that is more julia
dramatic that's just my way of thinking
i was attracted by tutoring
because i feel that they have pushed the
global frontier of how to do bayesian
statistics and it is completely
incompatible with every other system but
it is great it is really remarkable
and i feel you know that's the kind of
work we should aim to do because it just
takes us to a different level altogether
it lays the foundation for doing better
science in the future so i'm so excited
about using julia as a foundation to do
transformative things and so you know
when i look at the work done in data
frames when i look at the work done in
turin i really get inspired that we
should push the frontier and that will
also mean breaking familiar apis
so just uh you know one of the other
reasons
why the
copy stuff
[Music]
since we are discussing uh you know the
tension between uh bringing in uh
users from existing the languages are in
python it's it's also the ease of use uh
you know for me of course uh you know my
opinion is uh definitely biased because
i've worked with art for
quite many years uh but there are many
things which i just as a user find them
easier the interfaces are just easier
than
what i see
some with some packages with certain
operations than they are in julia
so while building a new package
expressivity as i used mentioned the
ease of use
also becomes an important point
that it should be the interfaces should
be more um
you know how do i put it intuitive more
natural
just feel natural okay you know if i
write this expression
i expect that this is
you know this should be the default or
you know there should be the argument
name
all right
so that is uh another reason for that
sort of tension even though you
want to do it in the julia way you know
not
you know provide it as a mandatory
argument but then you know r with r you
can everything is a keyword argument
right so just just a little example
so you you think hard about which should
be the keyword argument which should be
recommended to
and set some certain
you know sensible defaults
so i think that's a very important thing
because
now transitioning from
r to julia for the survey because
everything in r is like a keyword
argument so that was really difficult
but at the same time it's kind of nice
in r that you can tell what parameter it
is right like if you have f of
uh like 10 parameters then you can like
tell like if x equal to one y equal to
one so
i think that's quite nice in r which is
not there in julia and it was really
painful for me in in survey to do it
because then i couldn't do multiple
dispatch with keyword arguments
so the
can i go on to a next question uh
bogoman you have often emphasized that
we've got
some work to do on the foundations how
do we improve the convenience of using
julia stats
how do you think of base julia how do
you think of statistics and stat space
that you know how do we reduce the
entropy in these foundations and
what's our way to fix some of these
elementary
yes at least my perspective is that
so so
what
let me first comment what at least from
my perspective the tension is so
i believe that we need some statistical
functionality built into the language
because
when people want to calculate i don't
know mean they don't want to have to
install a package
because
it seems to be an overkill for some many
standard simple
functions to have to install something
but on the other hand
very quickly
you learn that those
functions that are provided by
statistics jl
so the standard
module
they are limited and
you anyway need to
have additional packages
for example the the corsi core of the
things is i think weights
but um because other functionalities
that
are missing in statistics like order
statistics and this kind of things
this is a separate
thing
but then
if you decide you you need something in
standard distribution of julia
then you very quickly hit another
problem but if something is in standard
distribution of julia
you have a limitation that you cannot
develop it too fast
because it will be only released as the
julia is released and also if you like
to change something you cannot change it
because
of the
non-breaking
policy in base julia so
[Music]
so this is
something that i think
is
really
difficult and challenging
at least my
my perspective would be
to have
a more complete package
that is
designed for support basic statistical
functionality so to merge
[Music]
statistics and stats base somehow into
one package but whether it should go
into
the
whoever then it should be statistics a
standard library module or rather this
should be taken out
as a separate
separate
separate package that has to be
installed i'm not sure i would go for
having a standard module
but
as i have said i understand that this
will bring us significant indications in
how fast we can develop
so this is at least the tensions i feel
but
my thinking would be to leave statistics
in base to have this standard
functionality but try adding things that
we are sure that
we want added
so that the
future functionality is more complete
from the statistical
user's perspective why i mentioned this
maybe the issue is that
for example those ways this is something
you need almost all the time when you do
statistics but for example there are you
know people in engineering who need to
calculate means quantiles and most of
the time they don't need
weights in the in their computations
because they have equal weights
if
in all of their data
so this simpler functionality that is
currently provided is
enough for them but from the statistical
users perspective which i understand we
discussed today is
and i am leaving this
bandwagon i i think that we should
put more functionality into statistics
module that it's more future completed
it's this is my
thinking but maybe especially
you who have migrated recently from r
you can comment
how you find it
you are muted
do others have comments on this question
okay we are towards the end of uh our
panel discussion i would like to just go
to our most important question what's
our way forward
what are the priorities for what needs
to be done in building the julia
statistics ecosystem how should we
organize ourselves to be more effective
how should we coordinate between all of
us on this call and the 100 other
important people who are developing
in this world so what are your thoughts
on the way forward what are our
priorities and how should we go about
doing it
for me i would say
really need a way forward to evangelize
and educate folks better
i had to use the word evangelize because
it's important
uh to you know continuously be out there
and tell people
and
you know ayush is doing in its own ways
in his office but nobody's listening to
him but
eventually that shift will happen
uh i am in the same space in the pharma
community where we're trying to move and
it is it'll take time you know it's
going to take a few years but
the early adopters are already loving it
it's just a matter of time so it's about
putting up putting out the right
education and evangelizing it and
standing by it i think that's more
important and there's no question that
we have to make it easy right there
there are always comparisons that will
be made to our but i think
in one area of focus should be uh
education
carlos what are your thoughts on the way
forward
yeah so i think i agree um
mentioning on sort of bringing up
bogamill's point on um
having sort of this
discrepancy between what should be sort
of in statistics and in base julia
versus what should be in um
[Music]
in stats base sort of thing i've been
wondering if there's like more we can do
to
uh make it clear to
new users what are the packages that
they are very likely to need what's the
sort of thing that
uh it would be really great definitely
to have um
just a
a sort of
more
um
more resources to help welcome people
into the community and understand sort
of like what they are going to need when
they are starting now so they don't have
to figure out um like what's the
difference between statistics and staff
space why are
different things in each one
um sort of thing
and even just for a lot of other
um packages it's i think very common in
julia to try to split everything up into
as many
um
different packages as possible and that
can be definitely very intimidating for
new users and i think we should be
trying to make more efforts to
sort of collect more of these packages
together um and make it easier for users
to
uh to figure out what it is they're
going to be needing
professor bates what are your thoughts
on the way forward how should we
organize ourselves how should we do
community building how should we
coordinate better with each other
yeah there's there's always that tension
there that carlos mentioned
between
having the uber package which is going
to encompass everything
and having a number of small packages i
don't know whether
one of the advantages of julia is that
it has the composability aspect to it
and we've seen that with
packages that really don't have content
like data api
that are just there to knit together
other packages in terms of defining some
generics
so
it may be possible to think of some kind
of statistics toolbox
and
i think that that would be
tied in with trying to teach
courses
and fortunately i'm out of that game now
but
uh
i don't know what
do
do we want to think about an
introductory course in statistics what
would be needed in julia or do we want
to think of more advanced specialized
courses i think we're still at the
point of advanced specialized courses
but
the concept of
what the community is is becoming much
more diverse we have
people who would identify themselves as
data scientists who may not be
interested in
statistics in the sense of distribution
and probability and statistics and the
typical model thing but they're
definitely
looking at streams for data and so on
we had people in machine learning which
still was a bit mysterious to me
uh
and
you know
how
do do these communities
they they at least should be talking
with each other people instead in
julia community who are active in these
do they need to be
somehow
knitted together i'm not sure
it seems that there's a lot of tension
between coalescing and
diffusion and
we're going to have to feel our way
through to decide exactly how we can
balance those those forces
what are your thoughts on the way
forward what should we be doing what are
our priorities and how should we as a
community organize ourselves to get
things done more effectively
well i think a couple of things we need
to learn very quickly one is
for example what
uh boho will say is that you know
missing data handling is a very
different uh story in judea
so maybe we can put up some you know
training material
of how to handling missing data because
in uh typical r python that is we take
it for granted
but in julia it's not so i think
the the aspect which is not so obvious
in julian
more training material you do video
would be
something we should take um
[Music]
on priority basis
another point i think uh with pressure
bets he mentioned that maybe
some more material on his introduction
to probability and statistics with julia
those kind of material
needs to put on
so uh i think more training material
what vijay says is more important and
um also the aspect of this uni codex
aspect of judea like you know you can
use effectively greek letters
in your coding
that is i think absolutely beautiful
thing of julia so i think that could be
one of the unique selling point of judea
and i believe
um
we
we should stress on those i think like
you know it is
uh
like being a statistician being trained
statistician we uh always um
uh think like you know like equations
first and you know the greek letters and
equations comes naturally to us
so and you are you can
codify it
so easily
that is one of the very strong point of
julia and that
should be one of the part of our
training material so and things i
believe as we just mentioned that you
know things will fall in place so we
don't have we are not in rush
so i think um that is what and of course
building up the community are reaching
out to each other is very and julia
discourse is great place to be
we need to introduce our students i'm
pushing my students to be active on the
julia discourse
so you know pushing our students to take
part in the julia discourse is also
another
uh thing
that we can encourage our students to be
on
so these are the things i think small
small things we have to keep doing
so hey uh
i think i totally agree with what uh
what
vijay has said and
his updates and solutions carried
forward is
the training and the education because
i feel all of us
scientists and engineers here we can sit
in our garages and keep working on our
little products
but what we do really need is more and
more users really so we do get out there
we need to reach
those
those people out there who are using
data
data scientists or statisticians
to use the the products that you are
building to use the language and the
packages
the more users we have
the more evolution people see
the packages will be will become better
so
yeah
welcome it over to you for the last word
yes so
my thinking is that maybe let me comment
on
the coordination efforts from the
perspective that
was
uh
related to those interface packages so i
think that
[Music]
a lot
a lot of things will be easier if we
really focus on thinking of those high
level abstractions that we can put into
packages currently there are
there is a data api package and
starts api taking those two packages are
meant to be interface packages
and i think that
really there are a lot of functions that
could be put there and
and if we standardize their meaning
it would make things much easier because
even such a simple function as predicts
i don't know
if you stumbled on it or not yet but
predict is not standardized in this way
and then if you use several packages
that allow you to do prediction from a
model
you have
several predict functions imported
and then there is a name plus
so this is maybe not a super
i think i mean that
i hope this is not a very complex thing
to do
but at the same time
it would
make teaching learning and using julia
easier because then you can say you know
there is a predict function for example
it's in general
meant for prediction
and whatever package you use
there is some common interface
agreed how is
how it should be defined and all the
packages that support predict function
follow it the same way and then you have
two benefits one benefit is that you
learn it once and reuse the knowledge
but the other is also that
such a common and intuitive name can be
easily used across packages because
currently if you have
if you have
you know a common name you have to
really think strongly whether you want
conflict with something else that is out
there in there in the package ecosystem
so how should we solve the coordination
problem where a whole bunch of us you
know need to come together and debate
this and come to some of these standards
because sauris here
a different strategy he's building the
crow package he's saying to himself look
i'm not waiting for the entire community
to coordinate around but within the
domain of my one
new beautiful package i'm giving you
this consistent api to a whole bunch of
statistical estimators and you know so
he he's making progress but he's not
solving the larger problem and you know
i see value in both that it's good that
he's building this package and it is uh
giving you a simple harmonious
consistent api for a wide variety of
statistical models but we also need to
solve your problem which is
that there should be a predict generic
so how should we go about it how should
we have a debate and write a standard it
sounds to me like an rfc problem
yeah so
so i think you know of course this is
not a simple
task but
what i would say that you know
if you move forward with exactly what
you have
described then
eventually it will become a de facto
standard but the the thing is because
this is the crucial thing is here about
naming
so if you
if you
see a function that actually you believe
that the name because the crucial thing
here is a name because it's related to
name clashes if you feel that you are
building
or developing a function that
actually can be merging
i would go forward in the package with
what you do but then to
submit a proposal uh to either data api
or stats api depending on what
on what kind of
functionality this is to discuss
whether a common api should not be
introduced and let me
give you an example of the recent effort
that we do
exactly in this way so
this is related to metadata so there are
many storage formats like formats like
packet or arrow
that are currently supported in julia
that allows storing table level and
column level metadata
but we do not have any
currently there is a general generic
metadata package for julia that
allows you to attach metadata to any
object but we do not have not
standardized on
on
how metadata should be handled for
tables so
what we did is the following kind of
what you have described so we went
forward to
define an api for metadata in data
frames that is an open pr in data frames
but in parallel
i have opened a pr to
data api
to standardize
what metadata should be on the table
level and why is it important because
when after we are done with this
then there are simple pr's to arrow jl
and parket to jl
that don't have to be data frame
specific but can be generic and we will
immediately have the ability
to save and load
tables that have metadata and
automatically they you know in a data
frame you will have this metadata so at
least what i do and actually if someone
is interested this is an ongoing effort
right now
that's the if i add functionality that i
believe is more general than just data
frames they are specific
in parallel open
appropriate
pr or issue depending on how you know
make sure the idea is to either start
the stats base
storage stats api or
[Music]
or
[Music]
data api to discuss
more general solutions
that
can
be done this way actually there is
another example of this just to give you
a brief
example of such a situation and this
this
this change
was
actually prompted
by some needs of the users so
there is a
a
commonly used function is in r that is
expand grid
and then we discussed okay it would be
nice
it was the idea it would be nice to have
it in data frames
but then we realized that
actually this is not data frame specific
functionality any table
could
be expanded like and you know you could
define the cartesian product of the
input columns
so what we ended up doing is exactly the
same so we added a function to the data
api
that says
i give you columns i give you a target
table type and materialize it for me and
in data frames we just have a specific
implementation that uses this general
api but you say just okay and the target
should be data frame
and then data frame is materialized and
of course the risk is that some users
might feel that this is an overkill that
we add this data frame but it's i think
it's not that bad because you are
explicit but at the same time if someone
in the future wants some other table
type to support the same you will have
the same function and other on on the
other hand i think that this concept
that you have many table types in julia
is something that people learn very fast
because when they read their csv first
psv file and use csv read they
learn immediately that the second
argument they have to pass is the type
of the target
table that they want to use because data
frame is on one of them so if you want
data frame you have actually to
explicitly say that you do csv into a
data frame
so
at least this is what we do
and those two examples are just of the
recent kind of this approach so what i
would suggest is that
go forward with your functionality as
fast as you can because we need new
functionality but if you feel that there
is some part of it that is more general
just open an issue or pr to the api
package to
make it generic
okay
just uh one question to everybody here
so
specifically to professor
so you mentioned starts api you
mentioned data api uh and i know about
tables or jail and how beautiful it is
you know it has eased the conversion
from one table to
one table type to another
but are there any other such packages
which
are
defining these interfaces
and you know as package developers we
need to be from what i understand is we
need to be aware of each of them just to
you know just to know where to even
raise appear in such a thing exists
right
yeah but that's why there are not many
that packages actually there are only
two interface packages at least in our
ecosystem which is
this data api and stats api because
tables jl
is not an api package because tables gl
defines an interface but also provides
implementation
the point of the data api and stats api
is that there is
no almost no implementation it's just an
definition of api it's like you know
abstract function i would say that i
don't say how it works i just say
what it does and everyone who wants to
support it
can reuse this name so then there are no
name clashes between packages
so
so in general
and of course then there is attention do
that everyone follows this
but i think that if you i am maintainer
of some package and i learned that
interface package defines some common
function
that then i'm likely to
follow
follow and just extend this generic
definition maybe one small comment is
for people who listen to this why do we
want packages that only define
interfaces without implementation
the reason is
that
this approach ensures that those
packages have a very low
dependency
[Music]
like burden so they do not introduce
many dependencies or on yet another
packages no class if you depend on such
a package you do not add a lot of
compilation type to your package because
those are super lightweight packages so
there is no reason that someone will pay
say i don't want to depend on this
interface package because it's too heavy
for me
they are on purpose very lightweight so
that you know you don't
you don't have to think whether i want
to depend on them or not
okay
okay um
thanks a lot uh
you should build it into the de facto
standard and then you know we should
come back and
uh think about how it can be generalized
much more so uh
if are there any other thoughts and
comments for the rest i will bring
this conversation to a close i thank all
of you for having been here with us and
look forward to engaging with everybody
who watches this video through
the future of the julia statistics
ecosystem thank you